well I'm joined now from Riga by the
president of Latvia egels Levitz thank
you for joining us uh this evening I'm
just interested Mr President when you
heard the original report that it was a
missile fired by Russia that had hit
Poland what were your thoughts
I thought that uh
the war is very dangerous not only for
Ukraine but also for our NATO allies
it's a dangerous for Europe and that
responsibility is of course on the side
of Russia because if Russia has planned
this incidence it is a very worse sign
but it is obviously or
our informations are saying that maybe
it is it was an accident but or if it is
a rocket
of Ukrainian Air Defense Forces which
defended the Ukrainian territory from
Russian missiles which targeted
Ukrainian civilians it is the same it is
our very worse situation and and we
should support Ukraine in this
war against against the unlawful
aggression of of Russia it doesn't
matter whether it was Ukrainian
anti-air
missile or it was Russian missile the
situation is the same polish territory
is it responsible for the war is Ukraine
and NATO is on the side of Ukraine yeah
responsible for the war is Russia I
think you mean I mean doesn't it
um sum up the dangers that some sort of
random event or some sort of
miscalculation or rushed response could
lead to something very bad
NATO is doesn't want escalation of the
war
therefore NATO is very cautious we have
to investigate
this incident but in general we should
support Ukraine because uh Russian
aggression against Ukraine is a danger
also against all NATO states of course
Poland latria and all NATO allies and
this incident is
a sign that the war is
dangerous also for NATO and NATO should
uh deal uh respectively that means all
military support for Ukraine Mr
President where do you think that this
war is heading
um
the war will I'm convinced will end with
the liberation of the territory of
Ukraine because we cannot tolerate such
attack to International Peace order to
international law
for of our state which is completely
outside the world Community which which
is committed to international law and
throughout peace order as it was
established in 1945 by United Nations
also this is a uh also an attack of
Russia against the world peace including
the taking back of Crimea
it is up to Ukraine to decide but also
Crimea is of course Ukrainian territory
donbassies Ukrainian territory her son
is Ukrainian territory also there are
internationally recognized borders of
Ukraine and Ukraine is entitled to
liberate the whole territory
are you worried that
um Western countries United States and
so forth May
um start to worry about providing
um so much Weaponry to Ukraine do you
worry that the commitment May waver
uh
NATO is a union of a Democratic states
and the Democracy cannot tolerate such
such an in infringement of law democracy
is based on law also international law
and therefore I think that the
Democratic states will continue their
support for Ukraine because the Ukraine
is also fighting for our European or
Western values Mr President thank you
very much for joining us I appreciate it
thank you
yeah thank you